Okay. I hope you enjoyed the course to this point.
In this lesson, we're going to work with a collection of
tweets. Now, I need to make clear that since this is
a collection that was gathered some time ago, it does not
reflect the state of Twitter feeds as they look right
now. It's a small snapshot in time. So our tweets had
the following form. So you can see that there is a,
unique identifier. There will be text for the tweet itself and
then an entities field. Now the entities field is broken
down into user mentions, urls and hashtags and we actually
took a look at one tweet, in the last lesson,
so this should be at least partially familiar to you.
User mentions, urls and hashtags represent that type of data,
and where it's found in the text of a tweet.
It's been extracted for us and stored in these individual
fields. Okay and then with each tweet, there's information about the
user at the time the tweet was made. As
you will see, our tweet documents actually contain many more
fields. We're representing those by the ellipses you see
in this example. As with the other data sets we've
considered, this type of data, is representative of what
you might work with as a data scientist. Many data
scientists are employed in spaces that work heavily with social
media. Google, Facebook, and Twitter are some of the most
prominent of thousands of firms, actually, that employ people to analyze this
type of data. Now, just for a moment imagine the types of
analysis you might want to do on tweets. Common for this type
of data is to understand the behavior of users, and the networks involved.
There are lots of ways we can do that. Now, one of
the most powerful things about putting our data in a database is
that most databases provide some analytics tools built in, that enable us
to explore our data a bit and get a sense for the story
it tells. In MongoDB, the built-in analytics tools take
the form of what we call the aggregation framework.
While not a replacement for map reduce in a
lot of situations, it does provide a powerful tool for
exploring our data, and exploring it whether we're auditing
the quality of our data or doing some analysis.
And with each major release of MongoDB, this becomes
a more powerful tool. There are several really valuable feature
enhancements actually in the 2.6 release.